so I wrote this list about so I grew up
in I would say upper middle class and we
know a decent amount of I would say like
top 10 men that's pretty common
um and I just wrote a list about like
what those men look for where I'm from I
know this is different a lot of people
would argue with me and say that but
this is just you know white suburban
community this is what yeah and I would
argue we'll go through this list I would
argue in any Community if you have a one
percent kind of man a lot of this stuff
is going to hit so I put just because
it's kind of small I'll just sometimes
put it like this absolutely
um no tattoos yeah my mom and honestly
this my mom told me not to date guys
with tattoos either really
um I think men can get away with it more
um but for the women
um Hobbies every weekend cannot be going
to the bar and looking like a hoe
well that's pretty clear yeah I agree
that's in line with what we talked about
you know what are your uh friend group
and what do you like to how do you turn
up no heavy male makeup eyelash
extensions no my brothers hate super
heavy makeup absolutely no heavy
eyeliner no shopping addiction like the
way the my brothers even if they make a
lot of money they still look at you as
like an expense and if stuff goes south
then maybe you don't have a lot of money
or they're still gonna have to pay
absolutely men look at everything as an
expense not just the woman the car the
vacation the house the private school
for the kids everything is a line item
that's just how they think so keeping
that in mind not only is it um costly
but also when you have all that stuff on
and you look like a
Runway a Broadway actor who is
complimenting you your girls
or the man that you want
it's often the men they don't want
because like that look that I have I
have a friend that like dresses like
like that you know
um and it's just like yeah like men
approach you but it's not the type of
men you want to be approached right what
are they approaching you for
yeah you know
um
so I put no piercings except ears
exactly so like belly button rings no
like the nose rings no
um and even the ears like none of this
up here it has to be you can do the
double or the even the triple
um but you can't really further than
that no
um you have to get ready in 30 minutes
or less because otherwise it's like if
we want to go somewhere and it's quick
like you you can't have this long
extensive routine exactly and that ties
back to what we said about all of that
elaborate makeup and it ties back to
um having your capsule wardrobe or
having your clothes that okay this is my
I wear what I describe as being ready
from like the carpool to the kitchen and
then you know also because I work remote
and I'm in Zoom meetings a lot I always
make sure that I'm presentable I know
sometimes people are like oh I'm just
running to the store but you never know
who you run into and a lot of things a
lot of times women don't think about men
are always is watching and they see you
from across the way and they may decide
to approach or not based on what they
saw you're you're making me want to
dress better
you do a really good job I've seen you
with and not a lot but I've seen you
with like more of a blouse on instead of
Niagara Falls I don't even know Pearl
it's like
okay this thing
um I've seen you wear blouses I've seen
you kind of curl your hair I do it for
the show like to me that's that should
do it for your man the show I know I'm
at like like okay I always think this is
like a behind the scenes versus that
with a million subscribers this is
you're right you're right you're right
I'm gonna I'm gonna improve Okay add it
to the list one thing at a time
um other thing no super long fingernails
you can get the fake ones but they have
to be like short like they can't I've
seen like women like their wives might
get them up to here but like it's it's
it's very usually French nothing too
crazy yes and I mean that is one of the
things that we you know learned about in
Etiquette and elegance classes they're
just some things that look
um more refined and there are some
things that look a little trashy I'm not
judging anybody but there's a reason
they call a certain manicure an active
length because
when a man is choosing you he's choosing
you for how you are going to be helpful
to him
I know we make an emotional decision but
a man can have an emotional experience
and then move on if you are not useful
to him Kevin talked about that wow
that's so interesting Kevin talked about
that a lot so there's so many facets of
that but when it comes to the nails not
only is it is it an expense and then
it's going to take time away because you
got to get them you know done I'm all
for a beauty routine I love you know
like Spa pampered whatever and my guy
knows that but I also make sure that
nothing that I'm doing to beautify
myself gets in the way of being an
active mom you know being able to cook
or clean or wash or do you know whatever
I just think the long fingernails in my
opinion it's kind of nasty because it's
not hygienic
um and then look at that and Kevin has
been known to say you know if certain
body parts are not up to par you know
you can you know draw your own
conclusions but yeah I just you know
hey man that I respect that has been
like look at those talents
um um I did put don't be an idiot okay
please clarify so okay
in my family now I don't know this is
just I would just say where I'm from
they won't date like the women
can't be dumb of course so and a lot of
times like my brother wouldn't date
girls because they were education majors
and he felt like a lot of our education
Majors were dumb because it's an easy
one yeah and and there's certain like
Majors that even from the women are a
bit looked down upon and it's not to say
there aren't smart teachers but there's
actually a study and you know
um teachers have a standard deviation
lower IQ than the rest of the population
actually yeah this is Thomas sowell's
book them the decline in dogma of
American Education if anyone's wondering
where to find that stat it's somewhere
in the book um I can't tell you the page
but yeah so
um okay so much for the substitute
but
um so like my there would just be
certain things my brothers like would
not date and it's like if you're gonna
do if you're gonna have no education or
career it's not a bad thing but you have
to have like
skills to back it up and it's very
important to the men like they don't
want a dumb woman raising their kids no
absolutely not I mean I agree you need
to be informed you don't have to know
everything about everything but I think
one thing that would serve like if you
are
um a little bit underperforming
academically and we know men don't care
about our degrees and all that but if
you do need to pick an area of study
study what he does be able to
communicate in his language let's say
I'm with somebody who's into real estate
I know nothing about real estate I have
a chemistry degree I'm like a you know
tech and and
stem person but I try to at least
understand you know buying a property
and hiring a team and doing that kind of
work that's not my natural area but it
shows a dedication to kind of get on his
program and at least be useful to him
because that's the language that he
speaks in that's the world where he
lives and breathes
creature we all Tendencies yet
um they want a girl with a fitness
routine because they also look at what
like your eating habits yeah so a guy
might see that you're thin when you're
young but if you're eating all this
stuff they kind of think this might not
be this much longer so guys look at like
your Fitness routine yeah
um good with kids of course
um knows how to cook having your own
recipe this is a bonus I forgot to put
on here ability to learn I actually
think that or not ability
to follow like coachable coachable is
huge because like guys will Overlook a
lot if they feel like they can train you
and that you're willing to be trained so
maybe you can't cook but you're willing
to learn it's like
metal I met my brother say like it was
absolutely horrible the meal she cooked
but I was just it was so I was so like
it was so sweet of her to like learn
this recipe or whatever absolutely and
that one ties back to what you had about
not being a majestic creature because I
don't want to blow past that because I
struggle with you know
um making healthy choices all the time I
know a big part of it was the stress
from you know working the way that I was
working but I take full responsibility
for what I put in my mouth but to your
point men really love when you try even
if you're not there yet you know we
talked in the beginning about I've lost
a lot of weight but I have a ways to go
and I get so much credit for basically
doing what I say I'm going to do and
every day make making incremental
progress
um so yeah that goes along with that
Fitness routine and
um you know being coachable and
teachable you may not get it right but
if you're making a good faith effort
that goes a long way with men I'll tell
you my brother's engaged and the girl
he's engaged to she's an engineer okay
so she's smart she makes a lot of money
doing that
um
and she went to culinary school for fun
oh that's a dream of mine
he's like there's nothing I mean she's
talked to him maybe I'll open a
restaurant or something I don't know but
she literally just went to culinary
school just to you know cook for him
yeah I mean for me and the way that I
was raised my mom is a retired hi Mom
home science teacher formerly home
economic so we talked about this
yesterday I just thought it was normal
but it's okay if you didn't grow up
cooking and doing laundry and cleaning
the house you can learn it and it's one
of those things like I never understood
it but you eat every day so why wouldn't
you cook every day but I know that's me
but at least trying and making some
shortcuts where you need to I think it
goes a long way it's it's a way that we
show love that's what we've done for
hundreds of years thousands of years
could you talk about okay because this
confuses me okay oh my gosh this
confuses me femininity
because a lot of times when women use it
it's so Broad
and there's never any real concrete like
definition of it that that I've seen and
then I see all these femininity coaches
that just say get in your feminine
energy and I'm just thinking what the
heck does that mean and I sort of
understand what they're saying but a lot
of times the way it translates to me
just the way I think is a lot of them
doing nothing and then saying they did
something ooh so it's like a lot of
women will like that coach femininity
will be these masculine women that are
clearly masculine like I can see it like
I'm talking to you I'm talking it'll be
like these girls that come on the show
they don't cook they don't do any of the
tradition but they're just in their
feminine energy
and they might say that they cook but
you can just tell when a woman talks
about cooking if she actually Cooks
because a girl that actually Cooks will
give you more detail and like a girl
that doesn't will say like like very
broad or I cook this or maybe like some
rest recipe she's seen her mom cook you
can just tell so like what is femininity
how do you improve it
yeah what what actually is femininity
and what are that like how specifically
do you improve it you know this one it's
interesting that you say that we
actually talked about this on my last
Wives Club episode that's the other
Channel that I have but femininity is
one of those things where
there is a dictionary definition and I
looked it up but it's also one of those
things it's a little bit elusive because
it's hard to Define but you know it when
you see it right however there are a lot
of buzzwords going on right now we have
that soft life era but it's not
something that you put on it's who you
are especially when you're tested so you
remember when we talked about like I
know that
I struggle sometimes with tough topics
and so I have to remove myself get it
together and come back because I don't
want to have you know an emotional
response those are the times when you
have an opportunity to be you know
masculine and you choose not to
consistently so for me it's so good who
you are
when you're tested okay right so when
the kids are hungry and they're pulling
at your skirt and they're like Mommy can
we eat if them kids is probably not the
most feminine response right so you know
we can work on that but yes it's it's a
buzzword that you know if people say but
they don't do then they're not feminine
because if you're truly feminine I don't
have to tell you that I'm feminine you
would pick up on that
right so to me and the dictionary
definition is something about having the
qualities or the characteristics of a
woman and when we had our last episode
on the wise Club I said you know for me
I really have been intentional about
studying men because I am a boy mom you
grew up between Brothers watching how
they act and doing the opposite so if
they come into a room and they're all
loud I bring my volume down I slow down
and I'm mindful of my gestures if they
take up a lot of space if they're just
like heavy you know stomping around then
I'm like oh okay
um and it is something that I had to
learn and we talked about this a little
bit yesterday with co-ed schools and
just kind of like being around boys or
any environment that you're in you're
gonna pick up on that whether it's the
corporate or whether it's girlfriends
that you know are a little bit messy or
whatnot so to answer your questions so
that I clearly communicate you know
being feminine is
the opposite of a man and I know things
have gotten Blended but I also believe
being feminine is being consistent and
being feminine is
um you know like I said when you're
tested when it's difficult but you still
maintain so as many of you know I was
just banned
band talk and
I'm Ties on
a platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible